we are here live at e3 on the GameSpot
stage I guess it's actually the Samsung
stage but GameSpot rug is underneath our
feet it's Games Montcalm I'm terribly
confused and we're just gonna go ahead
and get right into the demo its sticks
master of Shadows and joining me on the
couch is Julian desert Oh from cyanide I
here to talk about 6:00 Julian welcome
to the stage yeah thanks
we're excited to have you here because
sticks this is a stealth game yeah and
we have some serious stealth enthusiasts
on the game spot staff who've been
looking forward to this so we're gonna
take a look at the game in action you
recorded some of it earlier for us but
before we do that actually while we
watch it play out here yeah I set the
stage for us with sticks
so still sticks master of Shadows is a
stealth game and for for this project we
wanted to come back to the roots of the
roar and revisit it through a unique
character our our small Goblin sticks
and to clarify the roots this is also
sort of in the same world as the game of
Orcs and men yeah it's the same word but
it's not the same kind of game yes much
more about stealth action and a small
component of RPG with the skill trees
and the special abilities that you will
be able to unlock during the game all
right well we're gonna delve into that
in just a minute but yeah tell us a
little bit about Styx
he's a goblin what's what's his deal
what is he why is he an idiot thief is
he some kind of assassin
what's going on he is a goblin goblin
yeah he's a governing and his main goal
in this in this game is to steal a very
precious object it's the art of up a
tree okay a very powerful source of
magic it's a life link for the elves
that year is that our living around the
tree aha and also a powerful source of
magic for the humans that have built a
huge Citadel a kind of atrium around the
tree to protect it from the outsiders
and of course you with easy outsider and
so
Styx is basically trying to steal this
heart is it for zone 4
well gained or is it because you know
the humans and the elves are given the
goblins a tough time it's for his own
position you know he wants to have some
powerful magic who doesn't yeah yeah it
needs it is under addicts all these
skill are about amber you know social
abilities yeah okay so he's an addict a
kind of job okay and is that the glow of
his sort of amber yeah on his body there
and it's also an information for the
player when is in the lights or in the
shadow when you're in the shadow you are
you have the your tattoo unloaded so
that's sort of a visual indicator for
the player of how shrouded they are how
expose they are yeah and so we're doing
a little like throwing dust or sand is
yeah vertical weight says snuff these
torches no the humans they're not ones
to just leave the torches you know
sometimes you just darken an area in a
stealth game it stays dark but that's
not the case here this no this used to
be a writer on that's why you could be
able to can be able to I'm kind of
expecting six you just kind of just go
over there and like you know stick this
or and that nude and leave him behind a
barrel you know I'm gonna show the
lethal part of the game a bit later yeah
I wanted to show the sneaky way the no
use the use the shadows to make my own
bus so the goal being to just get past
these guys you know you could care less
about them you know what you don't you
don't get stabbed them you just need to
get by yeah it's up to the player to
choose if you want to play aggressively
or if you want to sneak and viateur
perfectly goes you know okay so then
that seems like it would are speaking of
aggressively yeah is this it just like
don't kill their you know okay
that's a silent kill as opposed to a you
know stick the sword in his back and he
screams or something like that yeah if
you're but it's a it's a little faster
when you feel aggressively aha but it
will make some noise so you don't want
to trigger an alert because it's a very
cognitive
Gaiman you know and sticks doesn't seem
like I was gonna say you know it doesn't
seem like a super formidable guy if he
gets mobbed but that was like a real
death from above Power Move yeah
so what just wait what just happen to
that body maybe sort of yeah all of it
or something yeah so special item it's
some acid if you can make people
disappear with that but you have to loot
them in the in the levels because it's a
very powerful item aha so you have to
pickpocket them on the NPCs or or loot
them in the in the levels all right so
we've seen sort of this you know you're
sort of talking about the playing
aggressively versus just sneaking right
by yeah that seems like it connects to
the whole skill tree thing don't you do
you put points into it that make you
stronger at one method than the other
yeah sure we have a six branch in the
skill tree we have the stealth branch we
have the agility branch the cloning
branch you will see that later in the
game aha in the demo sorry and you have
as well the amber vision branch and the
lethal one yes that was lethal all right
yeah the why I mean but so you hide the
bodies you know so that it's a classic
stealth move and he's really seem to be
a lot of places that sticks can get
under this yeah I mean you do it because
yeah yeah all right so it's takes is
sort of here we are and it's he's
infiltrating what seems to be some kind
of stronghold what he's infiltrating a
stronghold of the humans yeah but we're
in the game sort of story
does this take place this decision yeah
that's the only it's quite the mid-game
around the mid gamer so he's got some
abilities under his belt he's developed
his skills a little bit by the point
this guy died because uh before you
haven't seen it because we were talking
that I had poisoned the future because
you can use a lot of of ironmans to kill
people or to make sure ways so she sort
of set traps for that yeah you know he's
maybe you oh wait what just happened
it's another or is another sticks yeah
you create a clone of yourself
it's like a big bro a little brother for
you well it's much more a tool if you
want to die on retail you know so what
would happen if I try this oh you know
yeah totally didn't royal so gonna try
to take the long way around this guy
yeah no no it's not your big brother the
dorks because uh and 6-yard trained like
like God's own like the humans to
protect places you know so oh those big
orcs yeah I see here you you are going
to see a co-op kill what I call a
cop-killer wait when you have two guys
like this if you kill one it's better to
kill the two of them because sometimes
they are linked together so it will
react if it's friend disappears so my my
clone is a stunning Sylar wailing
another one and that gives you the
window it ago it's not the clone is it
isn't executing a kill no it's kind of
yeah distracting stunning like you said
telling you here I will show as well
that you can use your clone to to scoot
and then set up a place to to prepare a
trap a kind of trap so it's going down
you say a turn the light the light sort
of aha
and then you will see a another kind of
a cooperation with your poonam I'm
intrigued by this idea of sort of co-op
with your clone or you know having
another self yeah to line up and perform
these actions sometimes in the game we
have puzzle games as well and where you
need to cope with your phone to
further and is that puzzle game a
separate mode or is it sort of an area
you discover also an area you discover
with sometimes so treasure sometimes
it's a shortcut it's a you know as level
designer it was very important to have a
different way ways in the game to
explore and it's it's really as well for
the replay value and what we watch it to
have its different players experience
you know it's very important for us I
like that when a member of my team that
is playing the game for a long time is
coming to me and telling me on all I
discovered a new new way to go and a new
a new approach for a situation uh-huh I
think it's Rachel when when you're you
manage to do that I think that's a
hallmark of great stealth games is when
you do have those opportunities to you
know be creative in your approach to
have different ways to go about it ah we
have some questions coming in about
sticks from Derek's Anzhi yeah which I
will ask you as soon as you tell me what
that what invisible thing just happened
there so it's a special skill it's the
invisibility I can be a totally
invisible I will make noise but I'm
invisible
and it's so for a short amount of time
so you have to take care when you do
that and it costs amber your bottom
right is diminished yeah and it's quite
hard to find amber in the levels you
have a most of the time you have to
pickpocket the blog's but if you kill
the guards when they Falls you will
break the flasks so it's a kind of no
pain no gain because you you you have a
very strong abilities but we want the
players to explore or to take some risk
to to use them yeah
all right that question was from Derek
about basically about the size of the
world sort of is it open-world and more
of an assassin's creed bent or is it a
little bit more mission based like more
of a hitman type style
I guess sort of what you know what's the
level structure instincts yeah it's it's
not an open world and it's what I like
to call open a huge corridor it's a for
example this this part of a mission you
will see in the video
it's just alpha for one area from one
mission and what each mission are about
four areas so it's great to begin but
because you have a lot of different
paths Susan yeah a lot of different sort
of ways to approach no well Julian it's
looking pretty cool looking like a lot
of fun stealth options for sticks and
some neat mechanics at play folks who
are interested in the game when can
anyone you guys aiming for release and
what platforms you're gonna hope to
release it on so this game will be
released on PC ps4 and Xbox one on at
the end of the third quarter of this
this year great so just a few well a few
months away yeah tomorrow thank you guys
are getting pretty close yeah alright
Julian thank you so much for showing off
sticks I your work but was it shadow
master of shadows yes mix master of
shadows coming out later this year for
PC ps4 and Xbox one but very much thank
you
nice alright ladies and gents it's gonna
be back here live on stage for jump
tanks and if any of you fans are of
tense multiplayer battle maybe a little
flavor of Armored Core in it you're
gonna want to stick around and see that
we'll be back live on stage here in just
a minute